all right good morning everyone it's
10:20 4 a.m. game starts in 36 minutes
and it's a very important game today I'm
playing Keaton kilowatt he's in first
place he's six points high five points
so I'm kind of in a must-win situation
but I'm just gonna try and play chess
play good moves I have some interesting
opening preparation which I've actually
done did a few hours yesterday did a
little bit of reviewing this morning
just had breakfast had eggs cheese and
tomatoes and coffee and the vitamin C
supplements so um let's do some review
yeah I'm planning efore I would imagine
he'll be spread pretty thin because I've
played c4 d4 and e4 this tournaments
most expecting e5 who knows maybe he'll
surprise me but I just want to fight so
Knight c3 and now I'm most expecting a
six let's focus on this for now g3 I
would say there is maybe about 50%
chance we'll get this position I'll play
f4 and then before I mean this is just
based off his chest lock on games but
but yeah I mean I think there's a
reasonable chance this can this could
very well happen Knight a four five six
make sure this is where things can start
branching okay let's look at night f6
first c3 and then d5 I actually play the
game again stockfish last night I played
black stockfish played white sock fish
crushed me and this is a lie my players
black so I thought I was playing
reasonable
fish was developing castling I played
Bishop e7 I thought as the most natural
move and then BAM I five ticks take
takes and then d4 it's credible I spawn
this hard to defend black can't castle
what if black black castles here they
still take some mates f4 I mean what if
g6 so after castling let's say g6
I have this line too oh yeah we take and
then we go for the structure a d4 it
actually look looks quite pleasant for
whites you'll see black takes soon we
take with night so it should be seven
while still f5 takes on a TC six Queen
h5 insane and if this pawn takes
probably still eat six
that's nasty Wow yeah this f5 move is
very thematic I don't have too much more
time to review so you go through some of
the other variations if d5 right away
which I'm not expecting so much there's
a fun line here F 5 and then sack apiece
really going for the throw it to none
and some of these lines
let's talk I should prove of this and
this has occurred before say Bishop d7 r
g6
Kassem looks very natural
just curious with the eventual planners
see for oc4 with Bishop b2 ideas see for
Bishop f6 other than a five no so C 4 2
T of this knight c6
rookie one it's so patient why not
Bishop b2 on i-94 is clearly a fight
now a four also interesting
this is 95 move that has to play Bishop
f6 of 906 Bishop h6 Wow sown I have six
should f4 I like this D for coming d4 g5
Wow Queen h5 so nasty queen g4 ideas as
my t5 move is nice okay lots of
resources for the whites if it takes do
some quick review believe queen h5 maybe
it's better to keep Queens on the board
yeah maybe Queen h5 e 5 looks I have
three collars played this
and marriage for when I said yeah
soccer's ting g4 okay now h4 I have five
that looks very pleasant all right
it's a 1031 I have to probably wrap
things up in ten minutes I wanted to
look at this there's a game between
Jones and Ashwin I think it starts like
this I mean I think be for most likely
d5 ii was slightly in that night of six
there's all these transpositions though
so let's say i have 6 9 f3 d5 yeah this
game oh maybe they said Nigel short game
isn't there a Nigel short game in this
position white maybe not
but there's an f5 move like right here
yeah Fi okay so it's fighter off okay so
this is like a kind of nice key position
so if might start with my c6 f5 such a
nice idea and if it takes I assume like
g5 and vision h3 Knight takes Queen wait
how's light winning takes takes I need
to try my g6 just Queenie - yeah blacks
fumbling
okay so f6 was playing this already so
bad for for black so nasty and it takes
it takes d5
and then say night see ticks are we
taking we defend nice
okay Queenie - coming so let's see what
happened in this game f6 was played it's
brutal
well it's crushing okay and let's look
at the other line with g 6o g 6g for
interesting stock fish not so fond of g4
but let's just see okay why got in that
five I think it's it was at least in
this game easier to play for whites
those plans were very natural now keep
this d4 move in mind so the resulting
structure is very nice but d4 h 5 and
then I guess just play slowly maybe
build up h3g 4 ok let's go back so if he
plays might see 6 it should be somewhat
prepared for this so it's a secondary
move for him
now I'm just following this game musii
check Roberts pleasant position for
whites assume if g6 is some like b5
reddish of g5 probably five oh well I
turned on Stockbridge twice ie five take
six yeah that looks Pleasant if you six
the people ship g5 Castle queenside nice
counseling oh we just yeah we destroyed
blacks pawns okay yeah if I play Knight
f3
I think a six would be most likely and
then there's a nice game Greece shakal
fund I believe yeah all right 96 yeah
there's other moves here like g6
g6 I think it's so likely
and rook being one Bishop g7 be for her
what does this opening take stakes I
just want to play something a little
more slightly more normal let's say take
stakes let's just follow some line yeah
this looks very normal and he takes nice
96
super happened here it's nice to play c4
get the bind okay alright a lot of prep
here well that's what happens after a
few hours worth I mean this is just like
the final 15 minutes or so there's
another line so B 4 and then 8 9 a 4 D 5
immediately and there's some cool ideas
here maybe I should look at Bishop ticks
and they'll see for at some points
probably castling first let's say Bishop
Bishop d6 looks natural let's see 4
takes ticks ship b7 Queen b3 interesting
Oh f5 f5 again takes this is such a
thematic idea 9 h4 and if Bishop takes
g2 Bishop takes G - there's Queen e2
check
very fancy if a 5 I guess this is a nice
structure
and there's another line - which may be
more likely if Knight takes castling
whatever black plays like Bishop e7 or
knight c6 there's at five this is so
incredible g6 in them just c4 takes
takes yeah light has nice compensation
c4 is a threat here wait was it fun
Bishop takes h4 White's waiting despite
being down like all the kingside pawns
rook takes f5 so White's King is safe
White's just winning a piece c4 and
Queen checks on the horizon casting
Bishop takes d5 queen g4 King f on okay
one last thing before I go let me go to
chest bomb this I want to just review
money game okay switching to chrome so
this is a game that Dennis sporos
playing against him in a similar sort of
style I eventually got an f5 it was just
like completely crushing like all these
thematic ideas I'm just curious how much
time Keaton spent in the beginning so
play relatively quickly took like three
minutes on Queen c7 so I'm looking at
the timestamp
move very quickly in the opening and
then only started slowing down once the
position became bad and now I want to
see just his time Sam or his time
management throughout the tournament
also what's the weather what's the
weather right now okay it's not raining
but it's slightly colder than usual okay
let's just see time okay so he plays
quickly when he's like comfortable with
the position she move very quickly this
game move twenty five least twenty three
minutes okay
I'll play to this game oh this doesn't
have the timestamps
yeah seems like he's quick player even
if he's like not so familiar with
opening it's kind of similar to me
except hopefully I'm familiar at the
opening all right let's look at one more
you won this game wait what why do you
spend so much time Oh again didn't save
oh yeah I remember like glancing at this
game
yeah he's moving very quickly even
through this position okay good to know
um yeah I'm wrapping it up hope you guys
enjoyed that so they could be an
interesting day if I win there could be
a playoff but I'm just gonna try and
play a good game and see what happens
all right bye guys
that wraps up my prep sessions for for
this tournament unless there's a playoff
hopefully there's a playoff maybe I'll
record a session for that but first
things first
alright bye everyone